à quoi nous faisons face ce n'est rien
d'autre qu'une trahison une trahison
provoquée par les ambitions démesurées
les intérêts personnelsigogines ne doute
pas son plaisir dans les rues de Rostand
des selfies des poignées de main avec
les habitants
ils se retirent de cette ville dont il
avait pris le contrôle quelques heures
avant avec ses mercenaires les faits
divers nous montrent à quel point la
situation est instable à quel point la
situation est grave et préoccupante pour
nous tous en réalité le pouvoir russe
c'est un pouvoir d'inspiration mafios
c'est le mélangeant du KGB et de la
mafia hier à Saint-Pétersbourg les
quartiers généraux de Wagner ont été
perquisitionnés à Moscou les affiches de
recrutement ont été retirés à lattes
Russie qui apparaissait invincible
extrêmement forte extrêmement Unis
manifestement un certain nombre de
difficultés de terrain c'est évident à
des fissures dans ce pouvoir qu'on nous
décrivait comme extrêmement puissant et
affirmé en conclusion d'une journée
folle qui aurait pu se terminer dans un
bain de sang mais ces achevé en soirée
par un message vocal d'Evgeni Prigogine
c'est pourquoi conscient de notre
responsabilité dans les fusions de sang
russe d'un côté
nous faisons reculer nos colonnes et
retournons dans les camps de campagne
conformément au plan et là il y a un des
chefs hayons mafieux qui a défié le boss
mais en réalité c'est pas la fin du
régime de Poutine et
il faut pas qu'on oublie que se conflit
sera long qui sera difficile l'homme du
Kremlin a évidemment très peur et se
cache probablement quelque part sans se
montrer
je suis sûr qu'il n'est plus à Moscou il
appelle quelque part et demande quelque
chose il sait de quoi il a peur parce
qu'il a lui-même créé cette menace qu'il
requiert des Européens et des
Occidentaux en général une capacité
d'attention sur le long terme on n'a pas
l'habitude de ça nous dans nos sociétés
de poissons rouges et de zapping
a déjà acté son départ en Biélorussie il
ne sera pas poursuivi tout comme ces
mercenaires affirment le Kremlin
se planquer et surtout le pas parler
parce que il pourrait à mon avis avoir
une sorte d'effet d'effets des stations
malheureuse par contre nous on peut pas
faire nos calculs en fonction de
Monsieur prigogim pris gojin encore une
fois c'est un proxénète qui sort de tôle
et qui fait du fascisme son fonds de
commerce de son côté la Chine est restée
étrangement silencieuse pour le moment
alors que le président shejin ping et
Vladimir Poutine n'ont jamais cessé
d'affirmer leur relation étroite Gérald
Darmanin poursuit sa visite à Mayotte le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
est venu faire un premier bilan de son
opération contestée
à lutter notamment contre l'immigration
illégale pas de JDD dans les kiosques
quel journaux aujourd'hui en raison
d'une grève massivement suivie des
salariés contre la nomination de
Geoffroy le jeune le nouveau directeur
de la rédaction venu de valeur actuelle
c'est une opération qui évidemment comme
il est difficulté à ses débuts des
difficultés techniques des difficultés
juridiques d'innombrables recours que ce
qui ont été déposés des difficultés
diplomatiques et puis je pense que la
force de la volonté politique l'a
emporté
on se demande comment elle est arrivée
là cette voiture posée au milieu des
tombes d'un cimetière
conséquence du cyclone qui a dévasté
cette ville au sud du Brésil sur le
sujet que Geoffroy Lejeune qui vient
vers leurs actuelles prennent la tête du
Journal du dimanche il a soutenu Zemmour
pendant la présidentielle est-ce que ça
vous inquiète
oui oui parce que le JDD c'est le
journal auquel nous sommes très attachés
justement pour sa modération pour son
caractère pluraliste et la nature
domestiquée à l'extrême du verbe du
jaune du noir des couleurs qui dessinent
des pandas illusion produite par la
culture de différentes variétés de riz
soigneusement semées en Chine
[Musique]